l'aventure commence bien je te connais mon
dieu je suis ravi de faire une autre
science-fiction le
précédent est parti
hop on va te faire un petit tour qu'est-ce que
c'est que tout le monde de retour sur le
bateau maintenant
ce téléphone commence épique
le sourire  Je pense qu'ils veulent que nous
couvrons le combat ce sont des idées saignantes
parler d'évolution parler de création
qui pour moi est énorme ce que vous espérez
réaliser en venant ici pour rencontrer nos
créateurs pour obtenir des réponses là où ils nous ont même
frappés en premier lieu quand il le fait
qu'ils sont partis
ceux-ci travaillent des
magasins d'attaque très sophistiqués spectaculaires à la hauteur de mes
attentes ridley est constamment en train de
creuser plus profondément il est la vision la plus
extraordinaire suggérant ce
qui se passe là-bas c'est juste
incroyablement efficace quand il utilise la 3d
d'une manière que je  ne pense pas que quelqu'un l'
ait déjà utilisé comme nouvelle référence
pour la valeur de la 3d qui sortira
de ce film, vous devez utiliser une
quantité énorme d'imagination et de tournage en 3d, je
pense  la 3d est aussi bonne que tu vas
chanter vraiment mince à couper le souffle
vraiment je veux dire dans tous les départements, il est
au sommet de son jeu, il a une
vision très claire quand nous travaillons, vous connaissez
les scènes avec les costumes dans chaque
petit détail va balayer comme ils  faire du jogging en
bas de la colline il est incroyable il est mon
directeur de fantasy il trouve comment puis-
je faire cela différemment comment puis-je attirer votre
attention vous faire faire de mauvais rêves et de
mauvais frissons
bien sûr ce que je veux faire, c'est effrayer la
merde vivante d'ici
vous